after a 10-day hiatus the boats are back
calm seas give those waiting to cross
the hope that finally it might be safe
or not as dangerous
today reports that more than 200 people
arrived
nowhere near the 1 000 a day number the
prime minister had warned us about the
night before the government announced a
controversial new policy to send those
entering the uk through illegal methods
to an offshore asylum center in rwanda
the government says the nationality and
borders bill pushed through parliament
this week will deter people making this
journey a government spokesperson said
through this landmark legislation the
government is cracking down on people
smugglers and fixing the broken system
by making it a criminal offence to
knowingly arrive in the uk illegally and
introducing a maximum sentence of life
imprisonment for those who facilitate
illegal entry into our country
but the site of these boats some of them
brought in today
tell a different story
flimsy easily filled with water and from
what we know about how these people
smugglers operate they'd have been
filled with 30 perhaps even 40 people
suggesting maybe that the government's
rwanda policy isn't deterring everyone
what the uk government has introduced
does nothing to address the
circumstances of the people who are
compelled to make
these dangerous journeys
and since they're not addressed
i can only expect that many people will
continue to do so
whatever the uk policy
if their circumstances
are not addressed
this week's warmer weather forecast
spells a warning for those operating
these waters
expect more boats at sunrise
sadia chowdhury sky news in dover